a non-profit providing services to
nearly 7 000 children here in Clark
County is expanding and because of that
they are looking to fill about 50
different positions eight news now
reporter Brian will explains how Boys
Town Nevada is dealing with a pretty
tight job market we're expanding from 67
up to 92 schools that we've got support
in and we need to have to be able to
fill those spots Boys Town Nevada Works
directly with at-risk youth to help
curve behavioral issues in schools and
in homes it's an important job with
demand for services only increasing John
etzel executive director of Boys Town
Nevada says it can be tough to fill some
of these roles especially after
expanding his staff a hundred and fifty
percent in just three years it's
probably the biggest thing for us right
now is we want to be able to fill as
many spots heading into the school year
as we possibly can to get there they are
hosting job fairs and conducting
interviews on the spot even going as far
as offer bring up to five thousand
dollar hiring bonus Cynthia Mejia saw
the positions needed on social media
there's something about just the aspect
of it being
like facility that was said okay this is
more like me and same for IBN Mills a
college student at Nevada state so I'm
looking for something I'm interested in
my degree which is psychology so I found
that you know the boys home was
definitely ironed you know students or
anyone interested in the position
etzel says it's more than just money he
needs to find people who want to serve
the community goal is to be able to
teach them the right social skills to be
more successful in the future in their
classrooms so they're getting along with
teachers better they're getting along
with other students better and creating
less of a of a challenge for the you
know School District